good morning Hank it's Sunday no more
puffs I'm nine thousand words behind on
NaNoWriMo but I'm doing fantastic in
neanderthal November today we're going
to talk about the swine flu vaccine the
illusion of not choosing and injecting
filtered urine into your hip so Hank to
be totally honest even though I know
it's irrational I felt a little bit
nervous about getting the h1n1 vaccine
which actually hasn't been a problem yet
because I'm not a healthcare worker or a
child or a pregnant lady so I'm not in
the high-risk group although I do hang
out with a lot of children said the
creeper
which reminds me nerdfighters I'm gonna
be in Hinsdale Illinois this week you
should come hang out more info in the
doobly-doo and to be honest Hank the
reason I've been worried is because of
one woman Denise Jennings who was like a
cheerleader for the Washington Redskins
and then she got a flu shot and all of a
sudden she couldn't walk or talk and she
was having seizures and she was
diagnosed with this horrible incurable
disease called dystonia that she got as
a result of her flu vaccine and I was
like oh man even if there's a one in ten
million chance of that side-effect I
really don't want it to happen to me but
just as I was having all these
misgivings about the oint bark vaccine I
read a study that only 40% of parents of
American schoolchildren plan to get
their kids vaccinated and the number one
reason they cited was that they were
afraid of side-effects and then I found
myself thinking you know there's also a
side effect to not getting the oink bark
vaccine linked barf which is by any
measure much more dangerous to school
children than the vaccine which isn't
dangerous at all but more on that in a
second but because getting the vaccine
is an active choice and not getting the
vaccine is a passive choice it feels
more conservative not to get the vaccine
okay so back to Denise Jennings I've got
good news Hank she's making a full
recovery she can talk she stopped moving
weird which means that she did not in
fact have dystonia and the other thing
that hasn't been widely reported is that
the doctor who purportedly cured denise
jennings is bonkers for instance he
believes in this terrifyingly horrible
thing called urine injection therapy
where in your urine is filtered and then
put back into your body via a syringe to
boost your immune system which by the
way doesn't work this dude dr. Rashid
Butare is also one of the charming guys
who cons late-stage cancer patients out
of their money you know with promises of
miracle cures that never come to
now of course there's always the
possibility that this crazy dudes crazy
treatments actually do cure dystonia but
if that's the case he sure is a jerk
because he's never been willing to have
a clinical trial it's almost like he
knows he's full of crap so why is Denise
Jennings better
maybe it's because her initial diagnosis
acknowledged that there was probably a
significant psychogenic component to her
illness or maybe it's because she saw a
doctor who injects people with pee by
the way Hank I am NOT trying to enter
the vaccine debate because I fear the
giant squids of anger being like oh
you're not gonna get a vaccine to keep
me from kicking or bought I love you
giant squids of anger but I also fear
you so Hank I'm really not talking about
that what I'm talking about is the fact
that each moment in our lives we are
playing the odds and we tend to play
best when we play rationally I'll see
you on Tuesday you like my haircut ah
pepper that I shouldn't have done that